from his humble start as a standout
performer in the 90 sketch comedy show
in living color Jim Carrey has been one
of the hottest comedians in Hollywood
with memorable starring roles in Ace
Ventura the mask Batman Forever and dumb
and dumber
when hear the most annoying sound in the
world Carrie proved himself as one of
the best physical comedians of the 1990s
even his turns in dramatic roles like
The Truman Show and Eternal Sunshine of
the spotless mind were met with huge
critical success but whether you've
enjoyed him in big-budget comedies or
surreal dramas for some reason he's been
seen on screen less and less in recent
years so why won't Hollywood cast Jim
Carrey any more box-office confusion
back in the day Carrie's films were
surefire box-office hits but his more
recent films have been less of a
guarantee his more critically acclaimed
films don't make a ton of money and his
most profitable films aren't very well
loved while dumb in number two performed
well at the box office earning about 130
million over its budget reviews were
unkind non franchise films like the
incredible Burt Wonderstone and I love
you Philip Morris weren't financially
successful with Wonderstone losing three
million amid negative reviews and Philip
Morris only making a seven million
dollar profit despite largely positive
reviews studios want a star with a
predictable box-office draw before
betting on a big-budget film despite his
talents no one can be sure if the next
carry film will lay an egg he's not
winning awards by the early 2000s Carrey
earned four Golden Globe nominations in
two wins in a short period of time you
know when I go to sleep at night I'm not
just a guy going to sleep I'm two-time
Golden Globe winner Jim Carrey going to
get some well-needed shut-eye but
unfortunately he hasn't been nominated
for a major award since 2004 is eternal
sunshine at the spotless mind and even
though there was some critical buzz for
I love you Philip Morris he missed out
on all the major ceremonies Carrie's
biggest major awards recognition since
then was a Razzie nomination for worst
actor in the number-23 Razzie wedding
actors have turned it around before but
they're not always exactly what casting
directors are looking for controversial
beliefs since his relationship with
Jamie McCarthy
Carrey has been vocal about his stance
on vaccines
which he's called poison and referred to
pro-vaccine California Governor Jerry
Brown as a corporate fascist who must be
stopped while he's entitled to his
personal beliefs it can be risky for a
studio to go with an actor who could
alienate audiences with his political
comments especially those relating to
public health in addition to that Kerry
spoke out against his own film kick-ass
2 in 2013 after coming to the
realization that the ultraviolent comic
made him uncomfortable because of recent
school shootings again speaking out for
your beliefs admirable but this
particular stand wasn't something that
the studio's promotional tour managers
probably wanted to hear it wouldn't be
surprising if other studios took notice
lawsuit trouble as of the making of this
video
Carrey is fighting against wrongful
death suits filed by the mother and
ex-husband of his former girlfriend
Catriona white who died of an
intentional drug overdose in 2015
white's family alleges that carey
knowingly gave their daughter sexually
transmitted diseases lied to her
threatened her gave her the drug she
overdosed on and then broke up with her
to protect his public image
Kerry responded in a statement saying I
will not tolerate this heartless attempt
to exploit me or the woman I loved
he further called the allegations
irrelevant false and improper and a
shameless shakedown for money it's
entirely possible that Kerry's free time
might be getting sucked up by dealing
with putting these lawsuit issues behind
him behind the camera
more recently Kerry has been spending
more time behind the camera working as
the creative and executive producer of
the Showtime series I'm dying up here
the series draws from Kerry's
experiences as a stand-up comic starring
Melissa Leo as the owner of a comedy
club in the 1970s Carrie doesn't act in
the show but he's been actively
promoting the project and working on it
behind the scenes and Carrie seems like
he's pretty happy with life away from
the spotlight saying during a press
panel at the Television Critics
Association that he's in the process of
shedding layers of persona this time in
my life I'm very happy to be here for
these guys and watch these guys enter
this world and create these characters
how he can turn it around for Kerry the
secret to turning his career around
could lie and returning to the small
screen his appearance on 30 rock and the
office made waves I want
yeah I really do it's just the rest of
my family's in the Finger Lakes right
now I'm supposed to be in the Finger
Lakes right now so it's clear that if he
doesn't have the box-office bang
required to sell a blockbuster anymore
there's plenty of room to return to TV
where he could be a big fish in a
smaller pond who wouldn't want to see
Jim Carrey in a regular role on TV again
like many stars a hit show can help
revitalize his career and maybe even
lead him back to bigger movie roles in
the future thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to